DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO THEM.
>> JEFF, THANKS.
THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT.
WE JUST LEARNED SOME TEXAS
NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS ARE RIGHT
NOW PREPAREING TO DEPLOY TO THE
SOUTHERN BORDER AS PART OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S PLAN TO SECURE
THE BOUNDARY WITH MEXICO.
ARIZONA'S GOVERNOR SAID 150 OF
HIS STATE'S NATIONAL GUARD WILL
BE SENT TO THE BORDER NEXT WEEK.
NOW THE DEFENSE DEPARTMENT IS
GEARING UP A NEW UNIT TO HELP
DEAL WITH SECURITY ALONG THE
BORDER.
JENNIFER GRIFFIN HAS THE LATEST
FROM THE PENTAGON.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP WANTS UP TO
4,000 NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS SENT
TO THE MEXICO BORDER AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
SO FAR THE PENTAGON CAN'T OFFER
A TIMELINE AS TO WHEN THOSE
TROOPS WILL DEPLAY.
THAT DEPENDS ON THE SPEED OF
STATE GOVERNORS.
>> WE ARE LOOKING AT HOW TO BEST
PRIDE THE SUPPORT.
IT WILL BE CONSISTENT WITH LAW
AND THE SPIRIT OF CONGRESS.
>> THE PENTAGON ANNOUNCED IT IS
STANDING UP A NEW PLANNING SELL
MANNED 24-7.
>> WE ARE ESTABLISHING A NEW
BORDER SECURITY SUPPORT CELL.
THIS IS NOT BUSINESS AS USUAL.
>> THAT CELL MET FOR THE FIRST
TIME TODAY.
U.S. TROOPS WILL BUILD PART OF
THE WALL ON MILTARY BORDER WALL.
>> WE WILL HAVE OUR WALL AND GET
IT STRONGLY.
>> HE WAS REFERRING TO THE BARRY
GOLDWATER RANGE THAT SEES JET
DROPPING BOMBS DAILY.
THE BORDER PATROL EXPECTS THE
MILITARY TO BE USEED IN SUPPORT
ROLLS.
>> WE HAVE USED THEM TO REPAIR
ROADS AND VEHICLE.
>> WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP SENT
6,000 TO THE BORDER IT COST $14
MILLION.
ONE GOVERNOR SAID HER FORCES
WON'T DEPLAY.
>> THERE HAS BEEN NO PLANNING.
THERE HAS BEEN NO COLLABORATION
IN THE STATE.
THIS IS JUST SOMETHING THE
PRESIDENT REELED OFF TO DISTRACT
FROM THE PROBLEMS HE IS HAVING
IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
>> COULD IT BE 2 MONTHS BEFORE
ALL OF THE TROOPS ARE IN PLACE.